à la demande des familles l'hommage
s'est déroulée loin des caméras à
l'intérieur du quartier général des
sapeurs pompiers de paris
tous les compagnons d'armes du sergent
kart and has et du caporal jocelyn sont
là sur leur cercueil le drapeau
tricolore reconnaissance de la nation
pour le sacrifice de ces deux hommes la
ministre de la défense leur a remis la
légion d'honneur à titre posthume
le ministre de l'intérieur a salué leur
courage regarde et je vois le souvenir
du sergent simon carr pa naze et du
caporal nathanaël show soit avec vous
nous perdons deux sapeurs pompiers
brillant deux modèles de valeur de
modèle de dignité si mon kart and has
avait 28 ans ils étaient en couple
depuis dix ans âgé de 27 ans nathanel
jocelyn était père d'un petit garçon
tous deux avaient intégré les pompiers
de paris depuis plus de cinq ans il
servait dans le 10e arrondissement à la
sortie de la cérémonie
les pompiers ne retiennent plus leurs
larmes certains sont venus de loin pour
se recueillir
je suis venu
de l'yonne et c'est difficile quand on
perd on perd un frère d'armes un
collègue pompiers
c'est très émouvant le drame de la rue
de trévise a provoqué un élan de
solidarité des citoyens
plus de dix mille sept cents personnes
ont fait un don pour soutenir les
familles des deux pompiers
le montant de la cagnotte organisé par
les oeuvres sociales des pompiers de
paris a dépassé les 230 mille euros